Harry: From Yellow No. 5 to BHT,
here are all the most shocking chemicals
we've found in fast-food
chains in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Over the past season and
a half of "Food Wars,"
we've found some interesting,
dare I say shocking
chemicals in some of the
foods and food processes.
We've created this
compilation of these moments,
and Joe and I are going
to react to them now.
Sure, we may not be food
scientists, food experts,
scientists, or really anything,
but we do have these fancy lab coats,
which I think gives us some credibility.
I got mine at Party City!
Fantastic! Let's dive in.
You know, the only difference is that
our pepperoni contains beef.
Also preservatives
beutohydrolatehydrolazinase
and beautohadalidblahbityblah.
BHA and BHT.
I can't pronounce them.
They're bad.
It turns out that BHA and BHT are actually
subject to restrictions
in the European Union
and can't be added to
foods such as pepperoni.
This might be because
studies have shown that
BHA can cause tumors in rats
and it's therefore reasonably anticipated
to be a carcinogen in humans.
You have no idea how much we
spent on those dancing rats.
I mean, what doesn't cause
tumors in rats, right?
I feel like rats are always
getting cancer anyway.
And they don't say the portions.
Are they eating human-size
portions of BHA and BHT?
Then, yeah, of course
they're getting cancer.
Oh, well.
I'm gonna die doing what I love.
Eating banned chemicals.
Put it in my obituary!
We reached out to Domino's
to get some clarity
on the pepperoni situation.
We got our info from
their ingredients webpage.
However, when we checked with them,
they told us that their
information was incorrect
and they've updated it since
to say that BHA and BHT
have now been removed from the pepperoni.
I think this happened at
some point during 2018,
they couldn't say exactly when, but, Joe,
it sounds like you're OK after all.
Gotta say, my hair game is
pretty strong in this one.
I know it has nothing
to do with chemicals,
but my stuff was just [clicks tongue].
My hair's locked in on this one, buddy.
I loved BHA and BHT
because this was kind of
the first episode of "Food
Wars" where we found a chemical
that actually was kind of
banned and very dangerous
and didn't appear in the UK.
I'm gonna be straight up.
The European Union sounds
kind of like a buzzkill, right?
Is that what Brexit was all about?
"We want BHA and BHT in our food.
We're outta here."
And in the US, our doughnut is made up of
enriched wheat flour,
[fast-forward noise]
and BHT.
Ah, yes! Our old friend BHT,
aka butylated hydroxytoluene?
It is banned in the European Union.
The International Agency
for Research on Cancer
suggests -- might I say
strongly suggests --
"there is sufficient evidence"
that BHT causes tumor
growth in lab animals.
I'll tell you straight up,
those doughnuts could be
made of dead cancer rats,
I'd still eat them. They're that good.
Who cares what's in these doughnuts?
Also, according to WebMD,
BHT is also used to treat genital herpes.
That's right.
I want you to think about that
every time you bite into a Krispy Kreme.
Genital herpes.
And every time you get genital herpes,
I want you to think of Krispy Kreme.
I want those two things
together in your mind
for the rest of your life.
You are welcome.
Tricalcium phosphate,
diammonium phosphate.
That last guy, diammonium phosphate,
aka DAP.
Not the sequel to "WAP."
What does that stand for?
It is also used as a fertilizer
and as a fire retardant.
So, when we have the next
wildfire outbreaks in this state,
'cause it definitely will happen,
we're gonna start dropping
Krispy Kremes on those wildfires.
Problem solved!
One thing we need to note
about the US Taco Bell menu
is that items like the Baja Blast
and the Doritos Tacos Locos,
I think the shells have an
ingredient called Yellow No. 5.
Yellow No. 5 is not in the UK.
Of course it's in the US.
In the UK, you usually find Yellow 5
referred to as tartrazine.
It's on a list of six chemicals
which, when added to food,
must contain the following warning:
"May have an adverse effect on activity
and attention in children."
Tartrazine is a fascinating one because
it's in so many places in America
and basically nowhere here.
But, honestly, like, in
things like the Baja Blast,
I don't think that's what's
causing the hyperactivity.
I think it's the million
tons of sugar that they add.
As a medical professional,
you're not going to Taco Bell
because you were concerned
about what's going in your body,
you're going to Taco Bell 'cause
you don't care what's going
in or out of your body,
apparently.
In some cases, it causes itching and hives
in people who eat it.
Disgusting. [laughs]
Itching and hives? Yep! That's fine.
I feel most people who eat that food
already had itching
and hive issues anyway,
so if it's not coming from the Taco Bell,
it's coming from, I don't know,
sleeping on unwashed bedsheets.
Hey, I ate it growing up,
and I'm perfectly fine.
I should note that I have
a full head of gray hair
and I just turned 23.
What's up?
There are a few things to watch out for
on the menu at Five Guys.
Yeah, like the hot dogs.
For example, the pickles in the US.
In the US, the pickles
contain a food coloring
called Yellow 5, or tartrazine.
If this is added to foods
in the European Union --
My hair looks stupid in
the Five Guys episode.
Why did nobody warn me?
There is one thing to
look out for on the menu.
If you're in the US and you get a salad,
the croutons contain
azodicarbonamide, or ADA.
This is a substance that's
usually used to make
vinyl foam plastics, which
form things like yoga mats.
It's actually been banned from use in food
in the UK since the 1990s.
So, this is my comment
on the yoga-mat thing.
It's always something.
Even when we're trying to be healthy,
our salad has yoga-mat plastic
in it. It's ridiculous.
Like, why do our croutons
have plastic in them?
Just get regular croutons without plastic.
It doesn't make any sense.
Oh, my God, I want Pizza
Hut so bad right now.
I know it's weird to
stick up for a chemical,
but I want to point out
that to my understanding --
again, I've done no research on this --
it's not like they're making the yoga mats
and then taking the chemicals
out of the yoga mats.
If you imagine the chemical,
like, one truckload goes
to the yoga-mat factory,
and the other truckload goes to Pizza Hut.
I'm assuming, right?
Or are they recycling yoga mats?
If they're doing that, then never mind.
That's really gross.
The only ingredient in the US Chipotle
that gave me a bit of pause
was something called gypsum.
Gypsum's also known as
calcium sulfate hydrate.
Right? OK.
And Chipotle uses that
in their tofu process
when they separate the
chunks from the liquid.
Gypsum is also found in
drywall, chalk, and shampoo.
Of course it is.
Now, does the gypsum stay in the tofu
or is it just used for
the separating purposes?
I don't care.
I'm never getting tofu from Chipotle.
Don't worry about gypsum.
It's fine.
You know how they have
those billboards for --
Yeah, yeah yeah yeah!
Like, just this.
And then next to it is:
"Gypsum. Don't worry about it.
You're fine." [laughs]
One piece of information you can get
from the UK's FAQ page
is that the plant-based
Great Imitator wrap
might not actually be as
plant-based as it seems.
The baste and the tortilla
wrap used both contain shellac.
Now, shellac is also sometimes
called confectioner's glaze,
and it's a natural polymer that's used to
give things a waxy finish
and to trap in moisture.
Love the shirt I wore
in the Nando's episode.
What's your favorite Harry shirt so far?
Leave a comment below.
But where does shellac actually come from?
Well, it's actually secreted
by female lac beetles
onto trees in India and Thailand.
This means it's technically
an animal product,
and although it can be gathered
without harming the beetles,
this is hard to achieve in practice.
Not nice.
Shellac was one which popped out to me
when I was reading the ingredients list
just because the usual
context I've heard it in
is, like, gel nails.
So as soon as I kind of
knew that that wasn't that,
I wanted to do some more research into it.
And it turns out it's a beetle thing.
Who knew?
However, after combing
through their ingredients list
in the UK and the US,
we did find one or two
things to look out for.
For example, caramel color.
It's used in a range of Pret products,
from the dressing that
they put on their salads
to the caramel syrups, which
they put into their drinks.
Well, in the US, you'll find caramel color
in the salted caramel hot chocolate
and the salted caramel latte,
which I drink.
Caramel color is worth
pointing out because
it's on the state of California's
Proposition 65 list of chemicals
which are known to the
state to cause cancer
or reproductive toxicity.
Ooh, reproductive toxicity.
That's fun. Um. [laughs]
See, I was scared,
but the good news is there's only
two types of caramel
color, classes III and IV,
that contained the chemical
that's to blame for this, 4-MEL.
The bad news is that
class IV caramel color
does appear on the menu in the UK.
While there is some
evidence to suggest that
the amounts currently in
our food are pretty safe,
the state of California
banning it isn't a great look.
Meanwhile, at a federal level,
the FDA still says that there
is "no reason to believe
that there are any immediate
or short-term health risks
presented by 4-MEI at the
levels expected in food."
So, kind of up to you.
Whenever we reach out to someone
about something like caramel color,
the answer tends to be along the lines of,
"Well, you know, at its
current level, it's fine."
Then surely if there's something
which has a dangerous level,
then just get rid of it altogether.
It can't make that much of
a difference. Come on, guys.
The one other thing worth
pointing out is the difference
between the wraps used
in the two countries.
There's only one wrap used in the UK,
and it's this one, the kibbled rye wrap.
Here's the ingredients list.
We also have kibbled rye wraps in the US,
and the ingredients list
is virtually identical,
but we can also get a plain tortilla wrap
as part of the falafel and red peppers
and Pret's chicken Parm wraps.
The ingredients list for this wrap
is a little more alarming.
There's three different gums in here,
but it's actually the fumaric acid
you may want to watch out for.
It's an acidity regulator that's
pretty common in tortillas,
but the European Union says that
while it's practically nontoxic,
long-term exposure is
probably toxic to your kidneys
due to the results of studies
carried out on calves and rats.
Nice nonanswer. Like,
"We're not saying it's not,
but we're also not saying that it is."
Long-term effect, kidney damage?
I'm not worried about it.
Again, Dr. Joe says, "It's probably fine."
And then, on that billboard,
I have a cigarette in my mouth.
[producer laughing]
What we can get is a list of allergens.
And it has a couple of fun things to note.
For example, there is a
significant risk of there being
traces of seafood in
our banoffee concrete.
Did he say banana? Banoffee.
I'd be more worried about that.
What the hell's a banoffee?
And there are also sulfites
in our chicken bites
and in the ShackSauce.
We may or may not also have shellfish
in our 'Shroom burger, ShackBurger,
Shack Stack, and SmokeShack.
So, there's no potential seafood
in the UK equivalents of these burgers,
so I have no idea why
there might be shellfish
in ours here in the US. I
couldn't even guess why.
Still not been explained to me why
there is a significant risk that
there could be seafood in a milkshake,
because obviously that is not
something that goes together.
I do not want a shrimpy
milkshake. No, thank you.
While we might not have an
ingredients list for our bread,
we do know that it's
likely to not be perfect.
For example, an Irish
court recently declared
that Subway cannot call its loaves bread
due to the high sugar content.
Subway uses more than
10% sugar in their flour.
How about they can't call
their sandwiches sandwiches?
'Cause they're too gross.
The high-percentage amount
of their food tasting bad
is the reason it cannot
be called sandwiches
or edible food.
So, I actually reached out to Subway
about their bread issue,
and we did get a response from them.
The official Subway line on this is:
"Subway's bread is of course bread.
We've been baking fresh
bread in our stores
for more than three decades,
and our guests return
each day for sandwiches
made on bread that smells
as good as it tastes."
So, they're sticking with their guns.
Ireland disagrees. Whose side are you on?
It's worth pointing out one
other FAQ from the UK page,
which is that the UK
Nando's have explicitly
committed to never using
chlorinated chicken from America.
Chlorinated chicken's
been in the headlines
a lot recently because it's kind of become
the face of differing food standards
between the UK and the US.
It refers to the process of
giving slaughtered chickens
a chemical wash before they're packaged
and sent to consumers.
What do you guys have against
our chlorinated chicken?
JK. Joking. You're gonna see.
Oh, there's so many things
against our chlorinated chicken.
This is done to kill harmful
bacteria like salmonella.
Even the European Union admits that
it's unlikely to pose any
health risk to consumers.
But campaigners say that it also
allows farmers to cover up
lower production standards
throughout the chicken-rearing process.
The good news is that it's estimated
only 10% of US chicken
actually gets treated with chlorine.
So it's not a guarantee that
Nando's chicken in the US
will have been through the process.
But it's an interesting
example of the different
food standards in the UK and the US.
I'm perfectly fine with that.
Right? I'm perfectly fine with that.
Yeah, clean the raw chicken.
I mean, what would you
rather have, salmonella?
Get outta here. Like, it's fine.
I have never gotten salmonella.
From what I hear, it's
pretty awful. Trust me.
I am a diarrhea expert,
and it sounds unbearable.
Give me a chlorinated dipping sauce
with those chicken tenders.
I'm perfectly fine with that.
I am not fine with risking salmonella.
It's fine. Quit being a baby.
That's my third billboard.
[producer laughing]
[sirens]
Cops are coming?
You hear that?
Oh, s---.
I gotta write as many
prescriptions as I can
before they take it away.